Like a splash of cold water in the face, Aquaman
has arrived.
And though it's great, it's also a little
confusing, jammed with a century's worth of
undersea exposition.
Don't worry, though, we're here to help you
keep track of all those lost tribes and strange
artifacts.
So grab your life preserver, because here's
a spoiler-filled explanation of the ending
of Aquaman.
Arthur and Mera's search for the legendary
lost trident of King Atlan took them to some
exotic locales, but none were more unexpected
than the center of the Earth itself.
But longtime comic book fans know that if
there's one place you should always expect
the unexpected, it's the land of Skartaris.
See, in the 1970s DC Comics series The Warlord,
it was revealed that Skartaris is a prehistoric
jungle world accessible through portals that
connect it to Earth, and after the destruction
of Atlantis, a band of refugees traveled through
one of these portals to Skartaris and founded
New Atlantis.
Though Aquaman didn't run into any of the
citizens of New Atlantis during his brief
time on the other side of the portal, it would
make sense if the final resting place of Atlan's
trident was actually Skartaris, as it would
explain the fate of the "missing tribe" which
opens the door to a whole new world of adventure,
quite literally.
Once Arthur finally got his hands on Atlan's
trident, fans got to see an incredibly confusing
sequence where it seemingly lit up the nervous
systems of a bunch of random sea creatures.
There was no concrete explanation as to what
was actually happening, leaving viewers to
wonder just what exactly this mythical rident
actually does other than spark up what appeared
to be a bonus level from Tetris Effect.
Earlier in the film, it's said that the trident
gave Atlan command of the seas.
The prevailing theory is that the trident
essentially enhanced Aquaman's natural ability
to communicate with sea-life, amplifying it
to the point where he could exert his will
and actually control it.
That would explain how he was able to command
the karathen, as well as the shark mounts
used by King Orm's forces.
It even seemed to extend to the trench-dwelling
Atlantean descendants who had devolved back
into a more monstrous form.
You have to hand it to Princess Mera.
Not only did she save Atlantis, and the surface
world as well, she also managed to free herself
from an unwanted political marriage by replacing
the ambitious and scheming Prince Orm with
the much more suggestible and, well, kinda
dumber Arthur.
It was a brilliant maneuver from the real
power behind the throne.
"Let's just say, you do your best thinking
when you're not thinking at all."
"That was the worst pep-talk.
Ever."
And Arthur is going to need Mera's political
acumen, because he is way out of his depth,
no pun intended.
So far, it doesn't seem like he's even heard
the word "diplomacy."
Sure, a lot was made of Aquaman's unique ability
to bring the surface world and Atlantis together.
But you have to be able to do more than talk
to fish to get that done, you have to talk
to people.
And so far, that doesn't really seem to be
his strong suit.
Did anybody really think Black Manta was dead
just because his head exploded and he fell
hundreds of feet into the angry ocean, bouncing
off every single outcropping of rock in Italy
on the way down?
Of course not!
Considering the lengths to which director
James Wan went to in order to shoehorn Manta
and his origin story into a film that didn't
need him, there's no way he was going to be
written out that easily.
So what can fans expect from Manta in future
Aquaman films?
Well, comic book readers have a pretty good
idea, and it ain't pretty.
Way back in the 1970s, Black Manta was at
the center of one of the most shocking storylines
in comics history, as he finally got his revenge
on Aquaman by murdering Arthur and Mera's
infant son.
We're not sure a sequel will get quite that
dark, but Aquaman's dad is still alive, and
would seem like a ripe target for Manta's
vengeance… especially since the mid-credits
scene showed Manta teamed up with Atlantis-obsessed
researcher Stephen Shin.
In the comics, Shin was a friend of Aquaman's
dad who betrayed them both to satisfy his
compulsion to find the location of Atlantis.
So will things play out similarly in the movies?
With Black Manta and Dr. Shin working together,
not to mention the continued danger of Prince
Orm and the existence of Skartaris, one thing
is for sure: Aquaman 2 will have no shortage
of plotlines to choose from.
Besides giving him the ability to command
the creatures of the sea, the trident of Atlan
was also supposed to serve as the ultimate
trump card, granting Arthur the title of King
of Atlantis.
Yet, when he showed up with the trident to
try and stop the Atlantean civil war, surprisingly
few people on either side of the battle seemed
to actually notice or care, at least at first.
It's clear that his goal of uniting the seven
tribes of Atlantis is going to take a whole
lot more work than just raising aloft the
underwater equivalent of Excalibur.
As a wise man once said:
"Supreme executive power derives from a mandate
from the masses, not from some farcical aquatic
ceremony."
Becoming king isn't the end of Arthur's work:
it's just the beginning, magic trident or
no magic trident.